mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos lusti vierteln
die oscars stehen an
und werden anders als je zuvor viele
nominierte filme sind unbekannt kein
wunder bei geschlossenen kinos doch im
gehen die lichter wieder an zumindest in
der schweiz mit welchen aussichten schon
lockt seit 20 jahren leitet er das
ballett basel durchaus leinwand tauglich
[Applaus]
und auftritt studio na.de ein neues
schweizer mode und kunst heft mitten in
corona zeiten film aus einem kino das
auch archiv festival und
kompetenzzentrum ist
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kultplatz ja endlich
können wir uns wieder der großen
leinwand hingeben die kinos in der
schweiz sind geöffnet wenn auch nur für
50 menschen pro vorstellung wie aber
geht es dieser branche nach diesem
schwierigen jahr wie sieht die zukunft
aus und was strahlt aus hollywood zu uns
herüber das alles fragen wir uns wenige
tage vor der oscar preisverleihung
[Musik]
die oscars und sie soll es als erstes
gehen in unserer heutigen sendung und
die verleihung der goldenen männchen ist
dieses jahr corona bedingt sehr
außergewöhnlich im april statt im
februar statt den großen gewusel auf dem
roten teppich brav mit
sicherheitsabstand und vor allem stadt
mit publikumshits mit filmen die kaum
jemand kennt umso mehr wollen wir ihnen
jetzt ausgewählte werke vorstellen so
glamourös wie in den früheren jahren
kündigen sich die oscars 2021 nicht an
stattdessen werden die stars verteilt
zur bühne streiten in los angeles london
oder paris und damit erstmals auch in
europa dank mehrerer schauplätze müssen
die gäste nicht so weit reisen und
können sich besser verteilen
eine historische ausgabe auch bei den
schauspiel kategorie sagt rachel
braunschweig
sie kommentiert die oscar-nacht für slf
na ja interessant je der renommierten
schauspielerin aus film und fernsehen
fällt eines besonders aufwendige zufall
ist dass die nominationen da sie an ihr
so divers sie sind das ist sehr
erfreulich es sind sowie die zeltbühne
nominationen vorschau sport und
schauspieler mit nerd wies roth war also
verschiedene ethnien und das ist toll
von 20 darstellerinnen und darstellern
sind also fast die hälfte people of call
darunter sängerin endras nominiert als
beste hauptdarstellerin für ihre vergabe
und der jazz musikerin in der biografie
die united states
dazu war jonna days als bluessängerin
marines black bottom dass zwei schwarze
frauen gleichzeitig als beste
hauptdarstellerin nominiert sind gab es
seit 50 jahren nicht mehr
und beide gelten erst noch als
favoritinnen auch bei den männern ist
die auswahl diesmal diverse
[Musik]
si
damit spielt den sound of metal einen
drummer der sein gehör verliert dafür
ist der engländer mit pakistanischen
eltern im rennen als bester
hauptdarsteller
als erster musste
[Musik]
wien ist für seine rolle als
koreanischer einwanderer im
familiendrama minar ihn nominiert als
erster amerikaner mit asiatischen
wurzeln
diese diversität war für rachel
braunschweig längst fällig und ich merke
dass es wichtig ist dass die wohl models
sicher dass das anders wird und das
erste generation nur wo wird das dass
die diversität gesellschaft wo der
gesellschaft entspricht aber so wichtig
und tollerei eigentlich endlich abbildet
wird in der kunst und ihrer arbeit die
unser spiel haben müssen ein spiel für
die gesellschaft und es ist höchste zeit
dass die dem entspricht was ist bei den
oscars ebenfalls noch nie gab
zwei frauen in der kategorie beste regie
die engländerin emerald final ist
nominiert für den rachethriller
promising ihn wurmen
[Musik]
und chloe der nomad lehnt die erste
asiatische regisseurin ihr film über
moderne nomaden wird als großer favorit
gehandelt
in den bisherigen 92 ausgaben des
filmpreises wurden insgesamt lediglich
fünf frauen für die beste regie
vorgeschlagen
und nun also gleich zwei auf einmal doch
jetzt mal hand aufs herz welche der
oscar nominierten filme haben sie
gesehen
von welchen schon mal den titel gehört
wahrscheinlich nicht von allzu vielen
das film branchenmagazin variety stellte
nach einer umfrage fest sogar bei
filmfans sind die diesjährigen oscar
anwärter weitgehend unbekannt
[Applaus]
kommt in der kategorie bester spielfilm
noch am akzeptabel ssten weg von der
filmbiographie über black pencil
aktivisten haben immerhin 46 prozent der
befragten schon mal den titel gehört die
schwarzweiß produktion made über einen
drehbuchautoren der 1940 er jahren
hingegen kann lediglich 18 prozent
obwohl er auf netflix läuft viele der
filme gehen in der flut an
streaming-angeboten runter oder warten
noch immer auf einen kinostart
das hat natürlich mit hut und das hat
natürlich damit zu tun dass man die
ganze familie die ganze
produktionsfirmen und holt sich das
ständig verschieben
selbst für filmkenner innen wird es
dieses jahr an den oscars also einiges
zu entdecken geben vielleicht weniger
glamouröse gehoben
dafür umso mehr neue werke
und eine so große diversität bei den
nominierten wie noch nie zuvor
[Musik]
ok
das team von gesichtern geschichten
überträgt die oscar verleihung live
hellbraun schlag ist mit dabei in der
nächtlichen runde in meiner moderation
kollegin nicole weg
[Musik]
hier im stadtkino basel treffe ich jetzt
die chefin des hauses nicole reinhardt
engagiert sich stark für die lokale
kinoszene und ihr kino ist so etwas wie
ein kompetenzzentrum und kooperiert mit
anderen kinos etwa in baselland
[Musik]
ja hollywood strahlte autos und bestimmt
ist geschafft aber mit mannschaft ist
also so wie im letzten jahr wieder zwei
das pandemie ist stark in basel die
eigentlich für alle kulturinstitutionen
die schweiz natürlich als
herausforderndes jahr
vor allem das stop und go schwierig sie
immer das programm bereits halte es mit
spielen zu können oder spielen und den
abbrechen und bittet natürlich das
gefällt was trinos macht beginnt mit dem
publikum
aber wir sind froh dass mit angst der
öffentlichen unterstützung mit die
finanzielle anpassung sind und so kann
ich glaube sagen wir sind recht gut dass
yar'adua kann die absolut programm im
stadtkino basel wo man sich das genau
vorstellen
genau wir sind kreis premieren kino
sondern wir sind eine art - filmmuseum
das heißt ich stelle die große reihe
geschaffen die vor film historische
themen und griff neue spannen die
autorinnen und autoren hof das in trees
film pro monat wurden immer die richtige
programm hilft vorgestellt werden ja bei
ihm eigentlich programm haben aber ganz
großes archiv an er immer wieder per
drahtloser zeigen was hat auf ihrer
strategie das filmarchiv ist einerseits
sehr wichtig wie es kontakte schließt zu
anderen archiv wo von denen man vorher
keine kopien für dieses kino
das heißt dass bereicherung dieses
programm über filmen berühmt mit zeigt
die kopier selber und erstellen sie
eigene kino in der schweiz zur verfügung
wo es gebe mit so vielen filmen gott in
der not hat sich kinos vor anderen die
eine hand auf streaming anbieter wie
hand ausgelöst
mit dem herbst tatsächlich um es könnte
jetzt könnten kino zu streamen wolle
wenn diese bereit was wir aus diesem
programm zeigen könnte und hält jetzt im
ersten satz gespürt das ist relativ
schwierig ist die klasse kann man im
kino anzeige wegen land präsentieren
streaming und digitale plattformen
werden dass ich für euch in zukunft das
thema sie
und mir war die dies belege müsse was
man fürs zusätzliches angebot bringen
können dass er vielleicht nicht das
classic angebot von mir jetzt gerade
sondern spezielle premieren oder
zusätzliche inhalte jetzt sprach mit
regisseur und so gibt es gleichzeitig
ist streaming auf rot weiß und kino
kommen was haben sie dafür ihre haltung
dazu
also wir uns einfach mal glaube ich als
kind glaube dass das kino als diskus
führender ort immer brauchen wird
streaming ist viel guthaben also tolle
serie produziert wurde sind für netflix
hat film produziert wo die großen
studios nicht ein produzieren wolle aber
es gibt ganz klar und großer druck und
der druck werde wahrscheinlich die
großen mainstream regnet es spüre aber
auch zu die kinos mit sich mit einer
neuen realität auseinander setzte viele
blockbuster aus hollywood haben ja nicht
gezeigt werde jetzt im letzten jahr da
gibt's in der richtigen stau oder kino
costa sozusagen krieg vor dass das die
heimische läufer verdrängt
ich glaube dass die großen blockbuster
aus hollywood die werden die portale
meter große ketten xi in der arthaus
dadurch tatsächlich ein starker wille
seehofer internationale arthouse film
zeigt werde wenig also das wird arbeite
aber ich glaube durchaus dass sich
schweizer behaupten wird
das ist in dem crowe leiterin vom
filmfestival bilder in basel letzte hat
muss abgesagt werden da sie aus
hoffentlich stattfinden was ist der
stand der dinge ist das programm
stadtbildes zeigt der film wo sich als
test- und mutige filme wo neue visuelle
walter präsentieren wenn ganz viele
generationen und es wird auch das
festival sie das jahr wo die ganz stadt
ausstrahlen das wird bis wie es unter
anderem ein filmisches
stadtgeschichtlichen hauswand in der
stadt frankfurt
[Musik]
jetzt gehen wir quasi ein haus weiter
zum theater basel auch dort wieder
gespielt und ballettdirektor richard
wherlock feiert erst noch sein 10 jahre
jubiläum
das wird gefeiert mit sieben
choreographien auf allen drei bühnen
richard wherlock tänzer choreograf
direktor
der gebürtige brite mit schweizer pass
ist gesegnet mit charme und humor
ihm ist kein weg zu weit wenn es darum
geht dem tanz in all seinen farben und
formen tür und tor zu öffnen
seine erfolgsbilanz zeigt wherlock ist
auf dem richtigen weg er und sein team
genießen international hohes ansehen
zudem ist die kompanie trotz sparrunden
gewachsen
für den direktor des ballett basel das
ergebnis einer zusammenarbeit auf
augenhöhe
ich habe das glück dass ich aber mit
mensch nicht mehr maschine und das war
für mich ganz ganz wichtig an company
aufzubauen
egal von sexualität hautfarbe sprache
religion und accenture ein komplettes
also wirklich ein ensemble ist und ein
ressort von tanz nicht mehr nach
hierarchie und sowas aber das macht so
viel spaß wenn man sieht dass die leute
am spanier arbeit ja monatelang stand
die bühne wegen corona leer
jetzt endlich kann die premiere
stattfinden 20 jahre uhr lockt mit
sieben stücken an einem abend
ein pas de deux des jubilars und werke
die choreografen dem ensemble anvertraut
haben
der späte johan inger etwa oder der
weltweit gefeierter israeli pro vechta
das ein riesen kompliment auch für mich
in der company waren diese dieser super
grafen unsere komplette ich sagen hey
das war toll und ich komme wieder
balog wuchs in crystal aus bewegung und
humor hätten schon früh eine zentrale
rolle gespielt
eine art verteidigungsmechanismus gegen
stärkere jungs leute so lachen aber
durch bewegung man guckt charlie chaplin
ist ein wahnsinn was was er macht es ist
einfach super und das man meinen die
fans merken müssen
zum tanz fand er erst mit 16
nach einer ausbildung in london
arbeitete er mit verschiedenen
choreografen kreierte bald eigene stücke
und übernahm vor 30 jahren seine erste
direktion im deutschen haben schon
damals kämpfte er für toleranz und
diversität und als heterosexueller gegen
das vorurteil tänzer seien schwul
ich war immer so und dafür bin ich dann
soll eine große kämpfe
besonders am herzen liegt lockt auch die
nachwuchsförderung vor 20 jahren
begannen er und erwähnt der bennett
künstlerische leiterin der ballettschule
theater basel einen lehrgang mit
eidgenössischem berufsschulabschluss
aufzubauen
heute reisen studierende aus der ganzen
welt an
ein paar schaffen den sprung in blogs
ensemble andere in noch weit größere
kompanien wherlock erlaubt den lernenden
mit den profis zu trainieren
ein seltenes privileg ehemalige
ensemblemitglieder unterstützt er bei
der zweit karriereplanung der eine oder
andere arbeitet weiter am theater dass
sie sich auf anderen positionen
behaupten können liegt nicht zuletzt
daran dass warlock starke charaktere
persönlichkeiten engagiert thomas kolbe
wurde nach seinem rücktritt als tänzer
intern umgeschult und ist nun
verantwortlich für den vorstellungs
ablauf man hört ja tanzen auf in der
mitte seines lebens und stand plötzlich
damit nix und es ist schwierig neben dem
tanzen noch eine weitere ausbildung zu
machen denn dafür bleibt ihr der regel
weder energie noch zeit noch geld
die ausnahme bildet der heutige leiter
der lohnbuchhaltung und
personaladministration patrick außen bis
2014 tanzte er bei lok
ich komme aus frankreich da habe ich
eine story in mathe noch gehabt und
gesagt wie buchhaltung zahlen war der
richtige weg dann habe ich dafür eine
ausbildung ausgesucht als fernstudium
und ich habe es nie bereut
[Musik]
bühnenmeister noch heute sei warlock
sein ehemaliger chef eine
vertrauensperson mit 19 kam nicole in
die schweiz vor über zehn jahren zwangen
bandscheibenoperationen den einzigen rom
mio dann zum aufhören gar nicht
stattfinden
also ich bin immer noch obwohl man wenig
sieht oder nicht gesehen sagen also ich
bin immer nur teile von börsen und damit
auch teil der bevorstehenden premiere
tänzerinnen und tänzer bekannt für
verlässlichkeit und disziplin später in
anderen funktionen zu verpflichten eine
win win situation
damit heutige ensemblemitglieder alle
werden regelmäßig auf cockpit getestet
sich zukünftig auch eine externe
umschulung leisten können hat richard
wherlock jüngst einen fonds ins leben
gerufen von jedem verkauften ballett
ticket fließen 50 rappen in diesen fonds
in der schweiz eine pionierleistung
davon profitieren kann bereits raquel
ramos sie lernt bekleidungs gestalterin
und arbeitet nebenher an ihrer alten
wirkungsstätte als anklägerin gesagt ich
mach das ich schaff das nicht gehen so
wirklich und ich mache diese ausbildung
ich fühle mich vom theater richtiggehend
beschützt wie eine tochter
obwohl ich aufgehört habe zu tanzen
erhalte ich unterstützung ein großes
glück richard wherlock direktor
chefchoreograph botschafter vorkämpfer
vaterfigur 20 jahren hat er seine vision
in basel schritt für schritt umgesetzt
und wie denkt der 62 jährige über sein
eigenes karriereende
ich bin in new york nicht der jüngste
aber leide ich habe diese krankheit und
der krankheitslast der peter pan syndrom
weil ich denke ich bin immer noch 15 18
25 und das ist dann vielleicht dass es
dann irgendwie oder kimi görings
situationen weitermachen
stillstand hätte auch sehr überrascht
[Musik]
es ist ein wörtliches mitten in der
pandemie hat ein schweizer designbüro
den mut gefasst ein hochglanz heft zu
lancieren studio mehr gesehen so zur
plattform werden für renommierte
kunstschaffende wie auch für junge
talente ob das gut gehen kann
wir haben hingeschaut aufstrebende
fotografen und fotografinnen angesagte
kleiderladen des ufers dieses shooting
ist typisch für studio mehr gesehen
es will kunst und kommerz verbinden
[Musik]
herausgegeben wird es von einem zürcher
designbüro mit luxusmarken als kunden
mit werbe ästhetik kennt sich kreativ
direktor chardonnay also aus und macht
sich dies zunutze
antizyklisch während der korona krise er
hofft eine marktlücke entdeckt zu haben
meine bedürfnisse ganz einfach weil es
so weitergeht am kiosk
und dieses gefühl kann es ist der moment
ist richtig zum soweit bislang sie ihre
qualität wie wir sie jetzt erleben
im prinzip sollte man andere
selbstreflektion staub findet tritt für
sich sind fehlt an belegte sehen dann
studiere des kühlkreislaufs jetzt
realisierte positiv rang eins tiefgang
was zuerst ins auge sticht ist hochglanz
ein spiel mit kunstvollen teils
drastischen fotos
sie regen zum nachdenken an
sind aber oft auch werden hier etwa für
accessoires die verschmelzung zwischen
kommerz zu untergrund strecke die
verhörten und noch immer dort lebt eine
bringen also mich nehmen und dass die
trainer gar nicht so wahnsinnig sein
sondern wenn es stehen für beide
parteien den den soll das erstaunte dass
ich noch richtig
das schwerpunktthema der ersten ausgabe
war new realities eine gelegenheit in
einer reise armen zeit entdeckungen zu
machen
wieder sind shanghai teilweise
nachgebaute paris solche modeshooting
bilder gehen nahtlos in andere werbe
strecken über es gibt keine rubriken
wenig text kaum einordnung der fotos
zeitgeist in print mannschaft durch
papierseiten der inspiration braucht ein
krieg den station kommt mit dem mit kino
mit dem titel blätter mit dem moment wo
man ein bisschen text und ein stabiles
magazin will auch aufklären was sind
wiederkehrende strömungen was hat
bestand was liegt im trend
ein beispiel ist der hyperrealismus in
der malerei altmeister franz gertsch
trifft auf jungtalent francisco sierra
dessen foto realistisch gemalte
flugzeuge sind teil der sammlung im
aargauer kunsthaus das kunst und mode
heft erscheint zweimal jährlich in einer
auflage von 25.000 stück für 18 franken
noch sind die verkäufe bescheiden
doch das soll sich ändern mit fotos zu
prominenten künstlerinnen wie susan
bartsch die schweizerin ist in der
partyszene von new york seit jahrzehnten
eine große nummer
mit ihren verkleidungs shows wie
wandlungsfähig sie ist verdeutlicht das
making of video des fotoshootings bilder
davon erscheinen nun in der zweiten
ausgabe zum thema identität und pioniere
studio magazin will aber auch junge
talente berücksichtigen etwa den
südafrikanischen fotografen entdeckt auf
instagram kulturen eine breite gerade
aus afrika und der böniger dass sie das
kleine mit dem thema beschäftigen
charlene legt neu auch eine kooperation
mit der hippen könig gallery in berlin
als print plattform eine ausstellung die
zurzeit in der galerie und digital
stattfindet zusammen ergibt dies eine
publikation die kunstvoll sein kann
kommerziell sein muss und mit dieser
offen gelebten kombinationen ihren platz
finden sie
[Musik]
wir verabschieden uns hier aus dem
stadtkino bars und ich freue mich schon
jetzt wieder auf den ersten film auf
großer leinwand
[Musik]
jetzt folgt ihr die dänische serie die
wege des herrn und nächste woche
übernimmt hier meine kollegin ina may
des bonner damit richtig kreativ wir wir
sehen uns im mai wieder
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen will kultur
tourismus
[Applaus]